[Music]
but I'd like to show you today is
something in the way of an experiment
today's it's the view it's a
demonstration of augmented reality
individuals you're about to see are not
pre-recorded they are live and reacting
to me in real time I like to think of it
as a kind of technological magic so
fingers crossed and keep your eyes on
the big screen
augmented reality is the melding of the
real world with computer-generated
imagery
it seems the perfect medium to
investigate magic and ask why the
technological age we continue to have
this magical sense of wonder
magic is deception but it is a deception
we enjoy to enjoy being deceived an
audience must first suspend its
disbelief it was the poet Samuel Taylor
Coleridge who first suggested this
receptive state of mind for these
shadows that the imagination
four-wheeling uses edge
for a moment constitutes coitus take
this tape in the pits note is essential
for any kind of theatrical experience
without it a script it's just words
augmented reality is just the latest
technology and sleight of hands it's
just an artful demonstration of
dexterity we are all very good at
suspending our disbelief we do it every
day while reading novels watching
television or going to the movies we
willingly enter fictional worlds where
we share our heroes and cry for friends
we never had without disability there is
no magic it was Joe over who then
France's greatest illusionist who first
recognized the role of the magician as a
storyteller he said something that I've
posted on the wall of my studio a
conjurer is not a juggler he is actor
playing the part of a magician
which means magic a theater and every
trick is a story the tricks of magic
followed the archetypes of narrative
fate there are tales of creation and
loss death and resurrection and
obstacles that must be overcome now many
of them are intensely romantic magicians
play with fire and steal divide
occurring of the bus sauce there to
catch a bullet or attempt a deadly
escape but audiences don't come to see
the magician time they come to seamless
because the best stories always have a
happy ending the tricks of magic have
one special elements they are stories
with a twist
neither were they born or argued that
our brains are pattern-matching machines
he said that magicians deliberately
exploit the way their audiences think
stage magic relies almost wholly on the
momentum error the audience is led to
make assumptions or elaborations that
are perfectly reasonable but do not in
fact match what is being done in front
of them in that respect magic tricks are
like jokes jokes lead us down a path to
an expected destination
but when the scenario we have imagined
suddenly flips into something entirely
unexpected we laugh the same thing
happens when people watch magic tricks
the finale defies logic its new insights
into the problem and audiences express
their amazement with laughter it's fun
to be fooled one of the key qualities of
all stories is that they are made to be
shared we feel compelled to tell them
when I do a trick at a party that person
will immediately pull their friend over
and ask me to do it again they want to
share the experience that makes my job
more difficult because if I want to
surprise and I need to tell a story that
starts the same but ends differently
that's Rick with a twist on a twist it
keeps me busy now experts believe that
stories go beyond their capacity for
keeping us entertained we think in
narrative structures we connect events
and emotions and instinctively transform
them into a sequence that can be easily
understood it's a uniquely human
achievement we all want to share our
stories whether it is the trick we saw
at the party the bad day at the office
or the beautiful sunset with sonication
today thanks to technology we can share
those stories as never before by email
Facebook blogs tweets on ted.com the
tools of social networking these are the
digital camera
around which the audience gathers to
hear our story we turn facts into
similes and metaphors and even fantasies
we polish there are fetches of our lives
so that they feel whole our stories make
us the people we are and sometimes the
people we want to be they give us our
identity and a sense of community and if
the story is a good one
he might even make a smile
[Music]
thank you